one of the problems with urban planning
is that change is difficult most towns
are built around cars many of them want
to switch to something that's more
Transit friendly and walkable but it's a
very slow and difficult process but what
if the car never arrived what if your
town was so inaccessible for so long
that by the time it became possible for
cars to drive in the people decided they
didn't want them this is zamat a ski
resort in the Alps in southern
Switzerland and this is the end of the
valley there's no easy way past those
mountains you can't drive in here there
is a road but it's narrow and twisting
and only open if you get special
permission and pay quite a large fee and
even then you can't get into the town
proper instead the next town over has a
lot of parking and a train to shuttle
tourists back and forth it used to be
that the only Vehicles here were
horse-drawn carriages but in the 1980s
zamat modernized jumping straight past
petrol cars and internal combustion
engines and going fully electric with
some very specific requirements we don't
have private cars the hotel yes and all
the builders and all the taxis of course
can't go just by bicycle so they ask the
local government make the decision the
business people has to send us the paper
why you need a vehicle and then we have
this checklist we give them a permission
maybe for three years and if the
business is running he can keep it but
if you are a person like Tom Scott
uh why you need one yeah I like I I live
up here it's very difficult to go up
there then we would say sorry you can
take a taxi and all the delivers they
have a car but not the shops also not
the restaurants we are really strict
that since 20 years we have around 520s
Vehicles if you grew up in Britain
around the same time as I did you might
be thinking those are milk floats and
yes it's basically the same technology a
battery electric vehicle with a very
long service life designed for decades
of low speed use to be fixed easily if
it breaks and to make a minimum of noise
in the 20th century British dairies used
fleets of vehicles like that for
delivering bottles of milk to millions
of homes every morning which seems weird
these days but then so does a lot of the
20th century zamat here used these
vehicles for everything taxis are the
most obvious one but buses trucks the
police cars they all look like that and
many of them were designed and built
locally by a company just over there
that started out with horse-drawn taxes
in the 17th my father he was a horse
driver we had some electric cars with a
platform but nothing for transport
people
then my father he did buy with a company
near Zurich an electric car for
transport people
and then later on on
1985 I did come to my brother and we did
start with the factory symbol
we are building in a year about 10 to 15
cars and to build an electric car
for a small company like we are it's not
so easy here in our company we are 10.
and what you can see there that's a new
electric cars this one is the new
generation with lithium ionan batteries
before we did work with batteries in
lead
now with the Elysium yawning batteries
everything it's very easy you can drive
with this lithium and Technology will be
two three hours true it's no problem
anymore that's that what has changed a
lot this electric horse they are all
handmade I can tell you so every piece
you see at this car we have them many
times in our heads the other people say
the market is not big enough
that's why we can build them it costs
about 140
000 Swiss Francs the lifetime of this
electric cars it's about 30 up to 50
years that's no problem then with
aluminum we have no rust and its quality
it's handmade quality
it took me a while to notice something
as I walked around to that in every city
in every town there is a constant quiet
Roar of traffic noise from somewhere
even if it's off in the distance and
here there just isn't it's missing and
that's really obvious at night but right
now of course that's very difficult to
demonstrate because this construction
there's the rush of the river that's
really audible from this vantage point
it's carrying all the glacier melt water
down the valley there are helicopters
and trains but at night when
everything's calm there's no traffic
noise and while I know it's a one-off
and I know it only works because this is
a small rich and very expensive ski
resort with a weird history that's
outsourced its parking to the next town
over
I can't help thinking that it'd be nice
if more towns and cities sounded like
that everybody knows the rules the
children grows up with this can I have a
car are you crazy so it's it's in the
mind from the locals when I tell people
from Switzerland we are living a in a
town without petrol cars this is how you
manage by bicycle or of by by foot or by
a bus oh ah so they can't believe it but
if you are in this system then it's so
normal